assistant just said is there four
innings and basically hold on i said
what did you say a few days ago i
thought there were four innings but i
learned four innings recently that
there's nine possibly more if it's tied
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends
[Music]
hi you guys and welcome to unwaxed
podcast with your favorite sister sophia
stallone yes i decided that she wasn't
carrying her weight so we kicked sistine
out um yeah our computer's here just in
honor of her
presence in the past couple episodes but
it's okay now because your favorite
sister is back and i will be running the
show from now on i have so many good
stories i can tell you all the tea about
sistine when she's not here so you guys
today we are going to talk about
oh
hey
i thought we i told you you're not
allowed to be on the podcast anymore
don't get too comfortable sweetheart oh
my god
i started it it's okay the show has
finally arrived oh my god all right
we'll start it over and hello you guys
and welcome back to another episode of
the unwax podcast with your favorite
sisters sophia and sistine i'm frazzled
right now i just had a great intro i
said i kicked you off step by step for
two minutes
to do what
weren't carrying your weight we said a
certain time we said we're going to
share what she does in the restroom
sofia
i mean
early bird gets the worm all i know is
you're getting a lump of coal for
christmas all right
well we wanted to dive right in because
i'm really excited that something we did
a couple years ago that i've been dying
to do again
is vision boards
okay
yes before you get into the vision
boards and explaining what they are
exactly i would like to preface with i
thought
my mind has changed i thought they were
very dumb
and i thought it was just another excuse
for
sophia to you know
manifest stuff write things down burn
them
you know
pryon crystal i haven't steered you
wrong yet sweetheart
fair enough now
my mind was quickly changed when we
decided to recap what we had put on our
vision boards
and
pretty much everything came true it was
creepy we did it probably two years ago
yeah two years ago and to give a quick
spiel what we do specifically there's
different versions you can do um i was
set i went out you go to staples
wherever it is get two poster boards it
doesn't have to be that big buy a bunch
of magazines get some uh what's it
called tape scissors and just you
yourself and i and you just cut whatever
is feeling you at the moment whether
it's like no it's you're explaining it
poorly it's things that you want for the
new year
and whether you cut out certain letters
to spell words out for example if you
want love or relationship or money or
getting that job you'd
put out photos and words that would
symbolize those things and then you have
a whole collage of everything you want
just to clarify what i meant when you're
going through these magazines you might
see a photo that resonates to something
that you've been wanting and so it's
just whatever you're feeling because i
know that for me for example a couple
years ago
when i did it on the back i cut out a
picture of just a house for some reason
i saw this house in this magazine i'm
like i gotta cut it and put it on it i
don't know what it means sometimes you
got urges to cut a house i cut a house
into the vision board so i put it on the
back i'm like maybe this is my dream
home we'll see
i [ __ ] you not
she shouldn't you're not a year and a
half later i go back and by the way when
you have a vision board you don't look
at it at all you're supposed to like
leave it put on your bed bury it in the
dirt you don't look at it uh you check
it out like years later
i looked at the bottom of the photo and
it said florida
specifically
palm beach
tell me this right now i we never had
talked about that my parents never
decided to move that whole thing was not
even in conversation when i decided that
i manifested a great house for them in
palm beach you're welcome mom and dad
very good to me
what did i put on mine i put uh you made
it stupid in the beginning you put
pizzas yeah i put like a horse i put
pizza i think i just did things i liked
but then you know very subtly i threw in
their
relationship and love and skiing yeah
that was the creepiest one i had never
gone skiing or no i have but it's been
10 years and i cut out a photo of
friends skiing because i was like maybe
i'll go skiing
i'm going skiing at the the new year
yeah that was weird it was weird there's
a lot of little things i had on my
vision board with like wild romances
tell me why i wanted to do that to you
that's the weirdest year of dating ever
i manifested that i think also i put a
podcast studio before we even decided to
really do a podcast that's true i had
like literally i kind of had something
similar to this i swear to if you go
back it looked like as like a square
room with a ton of cameras and chairs it
was like building a brand i said under
it i don't know so sophia is
basically
going to set up this whole scrapbooking
day tomorrow yeah we're going to be
making new vision boards for the new
year and then we'll let you guys know
what we put on the vision board yeah i
would like to talk about um
something i actually heard on the radio
today and i was like oh maybe this would
be interesting to share on the podcast
sophie and i are a huge fan of
irish exits
and um
huge big
yeah massive fans
and i was thinking you know
with all these holiday parties and
gatherings happening
i would just love to hear
i mean people in this our studio
audience are you guys uh
are you guys an irish exit yes i'm
getting it yeah definitely
okay so i'm getting one no
explain yourself sir
he thinks it's rude you think it's rude
okay exactly so that's what someone was
saying on the radio the hosts were split
one person said
100 irish exit because you're not going
to remember
me if i say oh i'll be right back you're
not going to be thinking about oh is
gary coming back like you could just
slyly dip out yeah whereas the woman
said no i think it's rude if the host
invited you you have to say thank you
and goodbye yeah now they started
pulling up some statistics
and i thought this was kind of
interesting so studies show every person
for one whole year attends at least 25
parties
so you spend on average about 45 minutes
deciding when you're going to leave
until you actually leave the door
now
that saves two years of your life two
days
two
days two years
if you guys should do irish exams two
years of your life will be added on
here's what will happen you'll save the
fountain of youth
you would save two days of your life two
days of your life two days
two whole days you cut that out if you
smoke cigarettes just goes back a couple
days but you can add two days onto it
but also i read that if you eat a hot
dog you also lose seven minutes of your
life so we ate some dodger dogs a couple
of incentives can you believe that every
hot dog takes off seven minutes of your
life also
then my brain started thinking what
about the people that break records for
hot dog eating competitions
oh yeah
oh no they better be listening to this
podcast and start doing either texas
wait but i also heard some foods add
minutes to your life
um i wanted
no i wanted to say like salmon salmon
why do you say it in family salmon
salmon salmon salmon
what what what's up
what are legumes beans chickpeas oh oh
legumes they're like you know beans
beans they're good for your heart the
more the more you eat the more you use
yeah you know
the more we live but can i i actually i
think irish exits are the way to go just
because
maybe it's a thing that i'm lazy
we're good at it but i'll tell you we're
good at it but this is what i this is
what i say if you're like
one toe in the water with irish exit
what i normally do is i be line direct
to the exit and if i see people i know
i'll say bye to them on the way out be
like bye yeah i'm tired yeah but see do
you come up with sort of an emergency
excuse me no i just say i'm over it oh
see i don't know why my brain goes
straight to lying no you can't like i
don't know why i think of like the worst
case scenario i'm like
ah my dog is choking they're like auntie
glow is happening gotta go like i'll
just think of the craziest things
they're like oh my god don't touch me
that's so much worse and that's when
people get annoyed is when you have a
bad excuse because i'll tell you this
you're june and i attract that normally
when i do exit it's either to go home or
go to another party so if you're lying
oh you're going to two parties you
bragging over here sophia it says you go
to 25 parties a year so yeah i'm going
to two different parties but you know i
i vouch for uh but i do i do think that
if you're going to irish exit i always
used to use a funny excuse because why
because it sort of distracts people from
the fact that you're leaving their party
and instead makes them laugh and then
you just slip away while they're
chuckling i have a question then what
type of party are you referring to
because if it's a small party definitely
it's a birthday party
and there's about 40 people there
see i would always say i have to go home
and feed my cat and they'd be like
no i don't i don't when it's 40 people
birthday i'm not irish i'm saying if
it's a group of people at a table at
like a day club yeah i'm not talking to
anybody or if it's like a big big group
yeah i'm not saying hi but if it's a
smaller group i don't know all i'm
saying is those two days
i don't i want them
i do
okay i also read another statistic that
you spend what is it on the toilet like
how many days of your life
you spend sitting on the toilet you
there's a new study that came out what
hot dogs
oh do you hear that all right hot dog
lovers 30 minutes of your life every
time you chomp down on one
but
sometimes
the glizzy's too good
[Laughter]
you get all so sexual actually i the
last glizzy that i ate that sounds
horrendous coming out of my mouth um i
ate it with a fork and knife and no one
let me forget that what are you calling
it a hot dog
a glizzy
okay okay i love i love that you're
confused because i called it a hot dog
like a normal human being and they're
like it's a glizzy and i was like what's
a glizzy
that's called a hot dog i had no idea
actually until i don't even know i think
it's a dude thing it's a guy east coast
thing okay wait also the other fact that
you're looking for salted peanuts baked
salmon and rice
and rice and beans can add up to 10 to
15.
rice and beans
well that's kind of smart so let's say
you have a hot dog you counter it with
the salmon beans and rice so every time
you eat a hot dog make sure you eat the
sandwich
and there has to be a lot there has to
be someone out there that is like
logging all of the foods that they're
eating to like counter balance the
amount of minutes they're like losing
gaining losing i feel like that would
overwhelm me that would be crazy
i think we should talk about what
happened the other day
yes you guys the
continuous horrendous stories the tales
that come out of our apartment this is
the funniest story it never ends okay so
i'm i'm gonna just preface this because
we almost died
and i'm not even just joking about that
we almost died the other day um and this
was pretty bad actually that it got to a
point where my cousin had to call 9-1-1
so
i'll give you my pov and then i'll let
you take it over
i decide around two o'clock oh god i'm
hungry yeah i got a hankering for a
sandwich
i leave
pick me up some let's fix a bf1 too i
leave and i hear an alarm go off and
i'll go yeah it's an older building it's
probably just a fire alarm in the
batteries well down the hall we heard
one yeah and i was like i'll let it be
that's gone like 45 minutes so suddenly
i'm sitting on the couch with ryan i
just got out of the shower i have no
makeup on i look like ass
ryan's on the phone with his boss
whatever and suddenly we hear the alarm
come from the next room over and we go
why are there two fire alarms going off
like what is going on here why is our
building so shitty and old like no one's
alarm is working
then
ours goes off and we're like oh my grind
go check the fire alarm why is it broken
there's no smoke in here we're not
cooking anything he goes and checks the
alarm and it says
carbon monoxide
and we go what and he goes yeah it says
to get out if there's carbon monoxide
i'm like ryan shut up your overdram like
you're over dramatizing it turn it off
it goes no so if i really think i should
like restart it it says call 9-1-1 yeah
and um he's like i think i should just
keep this on or should i restart it and
i'm like ryan whatever and he restarts
it it immediately goes back on and he
comes downstairs he goes i i think i
should like be wary of this i'm like
by the way
me being alone i would have died i'm
saying to ryan leave it you're being
over dramatic don't call the cops ryan's
like i looked online it says put down
whatever you're doing and call the cops
right now and get out and so ryan calls
the cops i'm like ryan that's so
embarrassing don't call the cops yeah
you sniff all these cogs come on and i'm
like i don't smell anything but that's
the whole point of it um
and so he's on the phone he goes hi
um i'm ryan
i i just read online that
i the carbon monoxide if it's the alarm
is going off i'm supposed to call you so
here i am here i am
the guy goes
um okay
is other alarms going off like what's
going on he goes yeah i hear other
alarms and he goes okay we'll send over
someone right now immediately two
minutes later a fire truck comes so i'm
coming back from my walk sandwiches in
hand
and
i see three fire trucks outside of our
building and i have a video which we
will upload
of me trying to walk up my front door
steps with nine
fully suited firefighters hot
they were handsome hot like by the way
i'm not kidding i wish i was joking it
was like a magic mic show i'm not even
saying that because they were in outfits
it was like they all came it was kind of
stupid it was stupid like it was it was
really like shocking like did you guys
just pull from like a model catalog
probably and hire them so
i tell the guys i go i don't know what's
going on but i should probably get my
sister you guys were evacuated building
like i know but knowing her i should
probably go tell her because she'll stay
in there so let me go get in there like
well what floor are you on and i told
him what floor i was on and he goes oh
no no no that's this you cannot go to
your unit right now sophia comes
barreling out and goes no testing and
she
i'm not gonna lie you didn't look good i
looked horrible so this is the problem
so while we're in the apartment building
ryan's like so if the and there's like
three firefighters in the room he's like
so if you got to get out i feel a little
light-headed i actually like i'm feeling
the the carbon monoxide coming oh it's
exciting i am so embarrassed about how i
look i'm like ryan you gotta give me
like one minute he goes so we don't have
one minute i'm running upstairs brushing
my hair he literally drags me out
somebody's trying to look cute for the
firefighters when there's an actual
emergency they're like
get downstairs you're gonna die if you
don't leave the apartment i just need
blush hold on but i did cut it so uh i
worked it came out like a wet rat yeah
and um yeah so
we had a massive carbon monoxide
poisoning in our building but it's a
good learning lesson because if you and
i were living alone without a male that
would have
known to check this
no one would have called the police no
that's the thing is i that's why i was
saying i could have died because i was
being so nonchalant about it being oh
you know like the building is older
and it's everything breaks everything
leaks like nothing works and so i
wouldn't even assume i've never called
9-1-1 before so i would have never
initially done that and that's so dumb
lesson learned lesson learned i don't
know definitely it's like does it you
it's they call it you die in your sleep
carbon monoxide because you can't smell
it yeah yeah seriously i would have had
the longest nap in my entire life oh my
god sophia
merry christmas you know what else we
just talk about who we have on today
we have such an exciting guest on that
we've actually known personally for
quite some time and this is someone we
wanted to have on for a bit but you know
life as an athlete just doesn't stop yes
his name is jack flaherty he is a
pitcher for the cardinals yes oh my god
i'm doing so well uh he is a very
successful rising to the top baseball
player
i'm a little bit nervous to have a mom
because i just found out yesterday that
there are nine innings in baseball and i
thought there were four
so
what is that not right
four quarters are in football nine
innings in baseball that's see that's
why i'm a little bit all right um we'll
be right back with him and i'm actually
nervous not to interview him
all right you guys so this week we have
on a friend that we've had the pleasure
of watching
killing it in the mlb this 26 year old
powerhouse pitcher was selected by the
cardinals in the first round in 2014 mlb
draft i would consider him one of the
best pitchers in his field and we are so
excited to finally have him on this is
jack flaherty guys
thank you yes we are so excited to have
you on and um he was just previously
slightly roasting me about my dating
life so
rightfully so
i mean it's i think it's i think it was
fair i think it was
that's true no he does i i think steven
and i were in agreement there see you
guys i think so yeah i think we have
some unspoken agreements about your
dating life but you kind of do it to
yourself that's true you do it to
yourself you're the first athlete that
we've had on the phone interesting yeah
right yeah yes yes and then you have big
shoes to fill
how am i feeling i'm the first one i got
set a standard at this second well
what size shoe are you you have no shoes
13. 13 those are big shoes to fill two
sizes okay the next yeah the next
athlete has to fill in a size 13. yeah
13 and a half we're trying to set a good
standard which is a good standard but so
far so good kind of because i was
getting roasted i mean yeah you're
getting roasted it was i thought it was
fair you brought it up i i
it wasn't intentional that's true no you
know why the reason why i'm allowing
this is because we've known you for like
a while honestly okay so when you said
26 i i hate hearing it because yeah i've
known you since we were like 18
is that crazy or even i think younger
than that
17 17 yeah because so working on like
eight well i just had a weird flashback
we used to shoot imovies in my backyard
we shot a whole project hold on
do you remember i don't know i feel so
bad but it was for a school project and
we casted you as the creepy stalker yeah
the video of course i remember i think
you ended up hating the video yes i well
i was there for a good 30 minutes you
guys made me a creepy stalker and i had
to i had you guys have me like paint
something or like can i do it
i was the one editing and putting all
the creepy music oh my god i definitely
was the one that made you look horrible
yeah you put like mist in there you did
the soundtrack of halloween i mean you
put them in black and white it was very
you're like i have blackmail on you do
you yeah officially well you have that
yeah that video would be enough yeah
really so now um what i'm gonna request
is some tickets to see your next game so
then i won't release it or else i'll put
it on big screen oh it's going to say
nobody needs to see that no exactly
three minute three minute video well
hold on if all else fails and that your
baseball career so far i think we can
maybe add this to your acting resume
yeah that's true
so it's been pretty much baseball like
from day one like did you always know
that you wanted to be in baseball were
you doing any other sports before that i
mean i grew up playing baseball and
basketball mostly but i think everybody
around me knew that baseball was number
one i was always like one of my mentors
was my basketball coach and i was always
leaving
basketball practice to go to something
baseball like if there was basketball
going on i would miss it and i'd go to
baseball right and he always knew and he
tells me to this day he's like
you know some guys you know eat sleep
breathe right basketball he's like that
was you with baseball right oh and when
did you start playing baseball at what
age like i mean i was in the house like
swinging a like wolf about like three
okay so it was it was yeah
like we were like thank goodness i
didn't break anything in my mom's
apartment i was like three and
she let me throw a ball around and like
because your technique was so good she
knew you weren't gonna break anything i
don't know i think we just got lucky i
think we just got real lucky but it was
uh
yeah since real young and then like
organized i mean i guess i say organized
like t-ball like five okay true and then
you go into high school and was high
school kind of like the pivot of you
taking it extremely seriously and you're
like this is what i ended up wanting to
do or is it pretty much earlier than
that like middle school you're like i
think i had always taken it seriously it
was one of those things where
you know as we were growing up me and
like my best friend we'd always stay
after and for us it was fun like we
would do extra work and whatnot it was
fun and then come high school i was
still playing basketball and i quit my
freshman year like two months in because
they were he told me to go play
basketball like right just until that
was done then come play baseball and i
was like i don't want to do that i don't
want to give up right two months of
baseball to go play basketball so for me
that was
that was when it became real serious
right and then
yeah we kind of just played everything
was there was there a moment or a
conversation that you maybe had i don't
know if this was in high school or
middle school where
someone told you or you just had a gut
feeling that you knew you were going to
go pro like did you always know it was
going to sort of work out or did someone
tell you got out of high school
inspiration really no not out of high
school really no i was like
people would say it like oh you got a
chance to do this but up until draft day
like
we had because i was going to north
carolina so we had oh i didn't know that
that's why i was supposed to go to
school oh okay so i had flight booked
summer school classes were scheduled
okay because they they made the freshmen
go
early like over the summer to take
classes and get acclimated yeah so i had
flight books summer school classes
scheduled
everything for like two weeks after
graduation because you're ready to go
and the draft was the night before
graduation
and up until like my name was called i
was like i'm going to school that's so
scary wow and so
that's intense were you nervous about
the draft
like what's the feeling i wasn't until
the day the day of okay the day of we it
was
the fact that it all happened because we
were on our senior retreat okay oh yeah
leading up to it and so i think it was
the draft was on thursday right
and
um like what were you feeling when it
was coming up then i was i think i was
so distracted from and i was just like i
was so comfortable going to school yeah
oh you were fine with your like whether
or not i get it you were like i will
take either or that's a good attitude
yeah a lot of guys are i was like i'm
real happy totally so
but yeah we i remember i talked to my
agent that morning and he said
anything can happen he's like i don't
know and then it was so it was like up
in the air we drive back and we were
supposed to do some rehearsal at school
like when we got back for graduation the
next day i was like i'm i'm leaving
that's when i set in i was like i'm i'm
gone like the drafts in like two hours
like i'm like i can't do it
so when you got called to be um on the
cardinals how was that i'm feeling like
what was the emotion after all that hard
work you were doing i mean you probably
spent hours and hours and hours like
blood sweat and tears to get to where
you are now so
like being dry like being yeah yeah
i mean it was shock we were
having conversation in my mom's living
room like me and like four other friends
and an awesome
name gets called you see a picture on
the screen and we just kind of sat there
and like looked at each other like this
no wait you're so chill about this yeah
we didn't know what to do i like i like
curled up into a ball i was like kind of
i was i was like not embarrassed yeah i
was just like and i went over and hugged
my mom and she didn't know dude like
said it about 10 minutes later when
like her phone my phone everyone was
popping off went like off like she had
maybe a house phone at the time she
didn't unplug it because it was like it
was not stopped it was nonsense i would
have done back flips i would have just
sat there in a fetal position i was just
like well it was one of those like i
can't believe this is happening right
wow that's surreal though you mentioned
your mom because i know you've i've i've
met her before and you've always said
she's a big influence on how your career
has been like she's been your number one
that's how our mom is like she's been
there is she been like a ride or die
with like
everything has she just been your
confidant like how has she been a part
of
your success i mean she's everything
she's you know people tell me people
like to say that i work hard and then i
see her like how she was with her job
and i'm like
i hope i can work half as hard as she
would because she's going i mean she's
going not even like nine to five she's
going like eight to six comes home wow
would make my brother and i dinner
and then is working after that and then
wakes up in the morning before us at
like five mm-hmm makes us made breakfast
she would make breakfast every morning
because i wouldn't eat cereal you
wouldn't eat cereal no so why what do
you would have against cereal it just i
don't know we had cereal all cereal i
wouldn't i wouldn't do it my brother
would have cheerios i was gonna say i
was the diva and you were like i need it
he's like i need another benedict i need
i need something i was like
french toast or pancakes very good so
she always had to make breakfast up
until high school okay so it must be
hard though when you're constantly
training and you're on the road do you
miss her a lot when you're away oh yeah
i try to talk to her all the time yeah
that's good moms love that yeah usually
on start day like if i'm pitching that
day after night game i'll facetime her
and talk to her that's good
just to like just to have conversation
especially if i missed out on something
right
i usually try to what do you think you
did differently than people in high
school that got to where you are today
because i think that obviously a lot of
people when they're playing sports they
they want to be different they want to
stand out they want to have that
opportunity that you're having what do
you think that you did extra that got
you to the next if it was a mindset yeah
maybe you like did you say something do
you do something
because i always feel like
people that
end up in that successful position do
one thing or they had this like maybe
idea that i mean i think
like me and like our team like we just
we worked like we worked hard and it
didn't matter like we would have days
where
you know practice might end at five but
we're going home at seven right we're
doing anything we could
and then carrying that over
into the minor leagues and into the
beginnings of protocol but like i mean
we were going
so we would during the summers like we
were we'd go work out together yeah all
of us and we'd like caravan up there you
know 10 a.m up drive up to west lake
and then we'd go sit around and have
lunch but i think we just it was your
team it was a team effort it was a team
effort and i happened to it just
happened to this point some of it was i
mean some of it's luck some of it you
run in the right place no it's true
sometimes it's the right timing and i
think that you also have your special
abilities like you're really really good
at what you do some people just have a
natural gift well i also think it's a
different kind of
drive that you had because you'd
mentioned before that even when your
practice would end you would stay a
couple hours later because not even
training was bad for you like it was fun
to keep going
a lot of people don't want to put in
that extra 10 like they don't want to my
dad always says if you're going to be
successful at anything you got to arrive
early stay late and work as hard as you
can in between and that's exactly
what you did with your career so yeah i
think in a lot of ways yeah you say
you're like i don't know how it happened
and everyone on my team worked hard but
you worked just like one percent it just
it just had i mean it was there's a
little bit of luck involved there's a
little bit of i got lucky that
you know i had two guys who went the
first round like two years prior
so i didn't have to
go anywhere to be seen like i was a
sophomore of these seniors and there's
pro scouts there and and so it was just
like everything yeah they see this yeah
little sophomore i find that so
incredible that the three of you guys
were all recruited from the same team
like within the next first two something
i think you can't it's just it doesn't
even seem possible but what i find is so
crazy is that i have not seen you in
months and i know that the life and
lifestyle of an athlete especially
baseball you work on like how many
months out of the year like nine or ten
i mean we leave in february in our golf
see yeah for spring training
how do you train right now or yeah or in
fact when you go to so we leave in
february and we go i go to florida for
spring training they'll be probably if
we ever go to florida they'll be in the
same give us a ring yeah
yeah you guys are you guys are down
there right yeah we're always down there
but now that you're back what is like
the one thing that you miss doing is
there any place that you come when you
come back to l.a because you're gone for
so long i like going home do you like
doing nothing
yeah no i like going to my mom's and
like i try to go have dinner with her
like whenever i can and she'll she'll
cook or we'll just hang out and totally
watch a movie you're like just down time
i don't want to see anyone i want to
talk to anybody well don't get me wrong
i love seeing my friends and going
hanging out going to dinner and being
able to just have the day to do whatever
you want but yeah because we're in such
a rigorous like schedule throughout the
whole year yeah you're probably mentally
exhausted after just like it's nice to
come home and be able to to be around my
mom and be around my friends it's right
probably nice to sort of step away from
your
teammates because you're i'm sure around
them all of the time i kind of was
thinking about what is it like
when you're the new kid on the team
right because i would imagine it feels
like you're a freshman and everyone else
is a senior and you're like ooh
are they gonna are they great right off
the bat do you kind of have to earn
yours you got to earn it
but more does it earn your like their
respect
i think
this is so this is what it's yes
you feel like the freshman and then
there's
but it's a little bit different that you
know i'm 20 i was i was 21 when i got
called up in 2017. oh my gosh and i'm
around like
you're playing with guys somewhat your
age like i think in the level before i
was there's guys anywhere from
i think i'm the youngest it was like you
know 20 like 27. yeah but now you've got
grown men yeah with families oh yeah
kids and how do you relate to you know
their where they're in line you
you you don't yeah you don't really
relate to it you hope to find some
common ground on something and
eventually it comes down to winning and
the more that you go out and produce or
the more that you just show that you're
working hard right yeah guys are gonna
see it and
if you work hard and maybe it doesn't
maybe it doesn't happen right away maybe
you're not like really good right out
the gate
if you're working hard people will
notice that and they will respect you
were you nervous joining the team
because i from the little i know about
baseball i assistant just said is there
four innings and basically hold on
before you came in here hold on
hold on four innings
i know a little she knows we have it on
video you're twisting my words i said
what did you say a few days ago i
thought there were four innings but i
learned
recently that there's nine possibly more
if it's tied she just got told that
today congratulations but you thought it
was four where are we getting four from
i
and it's all there's a lot of four
quarters and a lot of sports okay
baseball honestly for so it's it's hard
for me to understand there are so many
different terminology and different
points scoring
what sport do you like to watch then
basketball because it's pretty
straightforward
there's a lot that goes on there's
different fouls and every there there's
there's foul calls you have everything
you're just like if it goes in that's
that's two points or three points maybe
um maybe something like archery
because it's just like straight
this is so funny um our cousin ryan she
was uh this was a couple months ago she
was like
funny she went on a date with the guy
this is not sports impaired who um used
to play football and so my cousin had to
get scrunchies and teach her every
position because he was kind of
expecting she was like yeah i know
football this girl had to learn one day
the entire lineup i watched half a
season of hard knocks in one night
trying to memorize the sport so by the
way it worked i go on this date
and
i start saying exactly what his position
does and what it like i couldn't even
repeat it today i have no idea
and um and and i was naming players and
i was naming all this stuff that sounded
fancy yeah and he was like oh my god
you can hang i was like well you know
he's like watch that that's how i dabble
he eventually comes out
that's the problem see if there was a
second date i was
screwed myself well your your boyfriend
played baseball so you should probably
learn a little bit about facebook you
got to watch it that's true he does
watch it he does watch it a lot he has
some learning to do
but
from the little we know about baseball i
know there's a lot of trading and things
that happen like that is it ever get
like scary i mean like because it's such
a high pressure sport i think reality
starts to set in like it's said in
recently of like the amount of guys that
i came up with that are now on different
teams or guys being in the like this
year was like guys were in
the locker room day of like the trade
deadline
hey you're you're getting traded and
like packing their stuff up
in there what's the emotions in there is
it just oh it's weird yeah it's just
like like all right like i wish you luck
you say goodbye like i'll see you
whenever we play yeah we'll talk um and
then you get new guys coming in you're
just like you're trying to meet them and
get to know them it's a that must be
intense yeah it's weird and then you you
know you play with guys you get to know
them like i lived with one guy for
you know four years in the minor leagues
one of my best friends and he got traded
this past no off season oh no no you're
right yes it was one of my guys but
it was it's for the better of the two
for the team yeah yeah i love him i
still talk to him all the time no
sometimes you have to like put that your
feelings aside and go like okay this is
for the team like maybe that's the best
for him too but whatever it is but it
must be just intense i mean imagine like
us living together also someone coming
up saying you're drafted to england to
dumb it off
yeah you got to go away for coming
the more we talk about um the sport and
the whole process of it the more i
realized how many emotions
they actually put you through it's
literally a roller coaster of feelings
that you guys endure
i would like to know
the feeling of you
look at this word standing on the mound
i wrote it down in our notes shut up
standing on the mound
stadium
right you're standing up the pressure
the bead of sweat going down your
are
temple
detailed here feeling
what are you feeling about hear anything
i've always been
at home or like oh is there a difference
let's say you're out of focus okay okay
while home everyone's like yeah they're
rooting for you at home it is if you
strike them out you win what do you hear
the crowd do you i don't
i don't um i don't i don't hear you you
hear nothing i'm like i i'm i'm on there
and i i
i can feel the energy and i can feel the
presence but i don't i'm not hearing any
of the words anything like i'll i'll
play off the
energy in the stadium like if it if it's
if they're amped up and they're loud and
whatnot like
you've got to find a way to use it like
use it to get you going or you get into
a big situation to get into the
postseason like that's crazy you use it
and it becomes fun so you use it to
propel you and you're like i want to do
better because they're like screaming
and that's so interesting i feel like
the only thing i could compare that
feeling to is
maybe when you have one too many tequila
shots and the room is starting to get
like crazy and you don't really hear
anything do you know what i mean like
everything's muffled no okay whatever
okay oh yeah oh that like you know what
i mean when that one hits and then it
just gets
foggy foggy and you're like you you're
you're in the room but you're like doc's
like no yeah
oh like i'm extra focused like i know
i'm in control of everything i'm not
telling your tequila
no i i'm in control of everything and
the the energy is it's so much so
exciting and you know you get a big
strikeout
uh at home in the crowd like they get up
and then you know next you know you're
you don't even know like you're fired up
your heart's going like this this is
such an adrenaline rush every time you
play like a really good game it's so
much fun so you and then you come off
and you're like or you're done after the
game you're done pitching you're
throwing whatever six seven innings and
right you hand it off and
like you don't feel anything until like
you're you're done and you walk inside
and then everything you know just like
crash so you don't want
you sound like you're really good in a
high pressure situation i enjoy it i i
work well under pressure i i i enjoy the
moment i enjoy those situations like a
big game intense like on the road and
it's it's fun going on the road
and then they get loud for right for
them and then you you get out of it and
then just silence right
so you're at an away game and it's a
really high intense pressure situation
like maybe it's down to the wire yeah
whatever it is do you do you have like a
mantra or something you say to yourself
before you pitch are you kind of because
i know you have a hashtag you put
everywhere which is i don't think don't
think is that
in relation to what you do that's in
relation to pitching yeah um
for me
so it started from
for me
i had to figure out okay when am i at my
best because it's really easy to
start pitching and like things are going
well and next thing you know you look up
and you see like your era going down or
what you start thinking oh i can what's
era
thanks for asking that like it's
your earned run it's the amount of runs
you give up every time you pitch oh okay
got it do you get that still nope
i got it just goes
important stat for pitchers and you and
then you start thinking okay if i pitch
another two innings then it's gonna
go down a little bit more and then i'll
be at here and the next you know like
you're out you've given up two homers
and you're okay for me don't think i
have to i had to think about okay when
am i at my best
what can i repeat mentally yeah to be at
my best to
continue to be in like this state of
mind yeah where
you know everybody talks about for
athletes being in the zone yeah okay
what is my zone well it's where i can be
on the mound
and have everything going on around me
whether it's chaos or silence silence or
you know something happens in the field
and just being able to where i tell
myself like i tell myself it was don't
think oh where i can
remind yourself i can
stand behind the mound and think about
the situation everything that's going on
but i've done all of the preparation
possible
to then when i step on the mound and get
on the rubber
yeah the i'm learning
is that the is that the notice the the
white line
[Laughter]
and i can step on to i can step on the
rubber and then not forget everything
but no i've prepared everything that i
don't i don't
have to think about anything i can i can
look at what the catcher puts down
and i can trust what i'm doing and trust
me i love that because you can apply it
to honestly anything you do yeah but did
you come up with this don't think
hashtag and mentality because you may be
choked in a very high pressure situation
and you did think and you messed up i
i think it came from like times of
really easily like losing myself on the
mound and
when i if i struggle or whatnot i can
very easily
um
over analyze
and i was thinking so you overthink yeah
so do i yeah welcome to the club real
easy to do really fun but you go and you
go and do something you screw something
up it's really easy to over analyze it
yeah okay i really do something wrong
yeah or
did i just mentally need to get back to
where i need to be yeah well especially
for you guys because i think that you
have to bounce back like you can't you
don't have time to
short memory right you have to have a
short memory because if you're if you
mess up a pitch you're like over
analyzing that one pitch like maybe it
didn't it was a foul or whatever it was
or if like your best friend gets injured
i'd be crying on the mound
and you can't think about that no it's
true your best friend what are you
talking about his best friend playing on
the team with him you got training she's
saying if somebody got hurt
hurt you gotta but he wasn't triggered
was he training cause he was hurt no no
that's just a hypothetical hypothetical
sorry i'm overthinking don't hashtag
don't think no yes
yes it comes from
knowing why knowing why you're good and
trusting that and knowing like i went
back to high school okay what was on my
what was on my mind when i was in high
school right and it was literally
nothing uh you asked somebody
what were you thinking when did this i
don't know it happened like
it happened things happened way too
quickly and so i went back to high
school
you know what was on my mind yeah
blank blank dots so now being on the
team what would you say i just thought
about this what would you say is your
greatest weakness and your greatest
strength being on the team like what do
you need to work on do you think what do
you think that you add on to the team
that's valuable um
i would say i add on to the team like
the i'd say the love and support i have
for my guys like i'm gonna push them
okay to
because i i know how good certain guys
can be
but i'm also always paying attention
like i'm not i pitch once and then i
take you know i'm off for four days
right and then i pitch again so in those
four days
like i'm working hard but then when the
game's going on like i'm watching
listening paying attention maybe pick up
something that somebody's doing that one
of my pictures is
you know they're doing something i can
have a conversation with them yeah or or
do that what do you think is something
you need to work on what i need to work
on
so when i when i pitch
i
kind of toe this line of
going like being crazy
and
but like it was being like an under
control crazy as well okay yeah yeah
i've pitched very well like high
functioning crazy yeah and when i'm
right on that line i pitch very well but
i can cross over it
and what do you consider crazy as a
pitcher is it like what are you doing
like uh
like a screw ball like a curveball
like like mentally or like if you like
what you're roasting me you're just like
that's a throw that's a throw you called
it
curveball screwball what are you saying
at all but no isn't it like maybe they
they're telling you to do a certain
thing and you're like i want to do my
own thing he's talking mentally
not physically yeah more more like um
you know you you can you can you can
like
pitch with emotion but like you can't be
emotional so if i'm on the mound like
getting like i'm actually pissed or
frustrated yeah i have to come out of
the game and i'm pissed and frustrated
and then i then show it too much
now it affects everybody else because
they're like
you know you can get looked at as
whether it's selfish or whatnot like
right obviously you're passionate but if
i can
take that like
frustration and like channel it the
right way then it's good if it goes the
other way
then we're in problematics have you ever
like slammed your mitt down uh yes
you get fined for doing stuff like that
i've never been fined but you could like
something i'm sure the team could
something have you hit someone in the
head not on purpose but i hit someone
that had this year yeah did you oh did
they get a concussion
why you sound so excited about it
i'm shocked that's scary you hit someone
in the head
it was a it was such a weird feeling i
was pitching very well
and
i just threw one pitch and it went just
and i right when i let go i was like i
was i went into i just crouched down i
was like oh no
oh they're wearing a helmet
they're locked did they walk to the
first place oh yeah
it was
a guy uh jonathan india and i felt i
felt bad
he got up he got up pissed i i tried to
talk to him but he got up pissed he was
mad
um i understood it i get it i know he
wants to hit the head i could imagine
he'd be happy no no he was he was like
thank you he was hot he was pissed he
was like
kind of yelling the whole way down to
first and
is he like that kind of no he was a
rookie oh but he he won rookie of the
year props to him he's a really good
player
um
i think i saw him a couple weeks later
and i was like are you like good like my
bad like yeah i was like okay that's
nice okay i would have done this if he
was still meat i would have said that
was intentional
oh my god
actually i planned that no i it was it
was one of it just yeah and then you
then i was like
i don't know about nervous to throw the
next pitch but i'm like you get this
weird feeling of like you don't want to
do that again yeah you i kind of and i
can feel it right now like a little bit
shaking i'm just like do your hand shake
i don't i don't oh god
i've only had my hand shake on the field
one time and it's because my contact
fell out and i had to put a new one in
and i'm like you have contacts to the
how do you do and yeah yeah your pitch
with one eye
like that no think about that wait oh
the contact falls out of your eye you
don't catch it with your finger you you
have to go get a new one they'll bring
one out to me and i think i had to put
one in
on the mound and stop and i'm like i'm
like this like trying to get it because
you're adrenaline and you're like oh
[ __ ] i can't oh my gosh and if it falls
have you ever tried to pitch without
your contacts i couldn't see anything i
couldn't yeah i implemented i barely
know that you guys were here like i know
it was you no are you nearsighted then
yes yeah so am i is it hard to date on
the road
um
it's in general it is yeah yeah well i'm
assuming you're gone for you're gone
from the middle of february and you
leave her on valentine's day which all
long time well do families leave on
valentine's day
so many girls heartbreaking that is
triggering so dude around the 13th
that's so lame dang it doesn't count
it's like you leave either right before
or right after or sometimes right on
that's usually around the date when it's
like all right and then would married
families then travel with you guys
sometimes don't go on the road so if we
go to chicago i hate hotel rooms no
thank you what i couldn't go out with
you guys it would be a lot but think
about it would you want to say a hotel
room every single city like it's not
about the place it's about the company
it's not every city if we go to chicago
families will come
he's like i hate room service well i
love room service
i mean it's they'll come on the road and
we go to a nice city and hang out and
get a nice steak yeah you go out to
dinner and you have a good time okay so
you've since you've been in the elmo
you've been in relationships you haven't
been in relationships like both ways
what would be like the perfect type of
person to date if you were having tried
very lightly on this question no no i'm
saying like what type of personality
does someone need to be to handle
someone that's always
from what i've seen from people that are
able to like make it work they're very
independent
and are okay with somebody being gone a
lot yeah
and i mean we'll go to team dinners and
whatnot and like you got you have to be
able to be trusting like hey we're going
out to dinner right we're gonna go we're
gonna go grab drinks tonight or
something right right yeah there has to
be a lot of trouble and we're gonna lie
we're in a different city and like
you know we're in chicago we're going
out to dinner as a team and potentially
in every area code is the the
catchphrase that's that's the stigma
with athletes is what it is but then you
know you also have to be okay with
i'm gonna be gone
from yeah one o'clock until the game
ends at 11. that's a long day so you
really need a true
nine to five gal something that is
preoccupied throughout the entire day as
well to be preoccupied but you'd be okay
like yeah yeah you you it can't be you
have to be flexible yeah it's like okay
like i'm sorry i have to go to field day
from one and i'll be back at like 11 or
you can come to the game hang out do
whatever you want the game's going to
end at we'll say 10 30 i'm out of there
by 11 15.
yeah home by
i don't know i wouldn't say 11 14 11 11
30 right right and then it's like if
there's a game like the next morning at
10 like okay i gotta go right so it's
just somebody who's independent is very
like confident enough in themselves and
trustworthy
is the key to making it work then like a
lot of communication communication is
very important yeah and just
communication and understanding yeah
because also for us we have to
understand that
it's not all about us like yes we are
going through high stressful high
pressure days yeah
the other person has had stuff going on
too and like there something may have
gone on in their day where it's like
that you missed right and maybe and
maybe and the the biggest thing that
guys
say whether it's in a relationship like
whether they have a family or not
is trying to be able to separate
you know the field from home okay so
whether it's like
the drive home
or
you know the bus ride back to the hotel
being able to
leave the field there which is a hard
thing to do because yeah
you go home and you want to think about
it you want to keep going and now you're
frustrated over yeah maybe you had a bad
game or the team lost and now you're
frustrated and you take it home yeah and
now you snap on
them you snap on what i'm hearing is it
might be easier to be single during
season
just to avoid
uh this is just my point of view i'm
saying this is neither pre knowledge
okay but no knowledge of anything
neither one is neither one is easy
because then you're but so so you like
to be in a relationship though
i i've done i've done both and when
you're in a good relationship like it's
really good it's really nice to have you
he's in a relationship or not right now
you're asking such tough questions i'm
asking general questions by the way okay
very generous what
go ahead
um
i'll i'll go back to my question ignores
okay
i would say analyzing it's easier
to be single because i feel like i would
do the same thing if i'm not around that
person for me i'm very independent and
sometimes it's out of sight out of mind
and i wouldn't think oh my god i'm
supposed to text them
and uh check in on them and all the
stuff then they get insecure i totally
get that
so why do you prefer sometimes when it's
really good to be in a relationship do
they travel to meet you like how do you
when you're in a good one like they
understand like yeah when you go to the
field like i'm not carrying my phone
around the whole time like i may not
talk to you for a couple hours and then
the game goes on like that's three hours
i'm not by my phone yeah um
you know spring like spring training
days it's like six a.m until two
so the schedule's completely changing
but yeah then you have the whole
afternoons but they come visit you hang
out you're able to get that time you'll
spend you know four or five days
together and maybe they they stay maybe
they go on the road
um
and you're able to just spend quality
time as long as the person is like
understanding of your career and
understanding yeah sometimes you can't
really help it yeah and maybe they think
it's yeah i feel like i could be wrong
as well
but i feel like someone in your position
they would almost judge you for not
doing that and you're like no it's
literally my job i can't help my hours
and i can't help them out it's hard to
be understanding that with somebody else
like
you're being so sympathetic for seeing
the other side yeah okay if
if you were you know if you jump into a
relationship with somebody and you don't
know too much about like the sport and
you're like oh my god this guy's gone
from
they come visit and like you try to
explain yeah i'm gonna be gone from one
until like 10 30 tonight yeah
like
what am i supposed to do for seven eight
hours what am i gonna do for six hours
until they get yeah take up a hobby i
don't know like
that's a lot of but that's a lot of time
to figure out okay what do i do right
right right well we'll pivot away from
girls i can see yourself i'm just
no i'm not sweating like it's not an
easy thing to do you're actually
answering it beautifully and the and the
y and like the wives like they'll have
their they have their kids that they can
that they
yeah that's right do you have any crazy
stalker fans yeah i was going to ask do
you have any crazy stalkers yeah do you
have a maybe even if it's a few dm maybe
if that's a girl or a guy like have you
ever had someone just come to every
single game or your hotel that just
no because i love you it's so nice never
never had anything like how does it feel
no it i mean it's it's let us know what
is nice not having what a nice life
we have some crazy
crazy stalkers no no we have like
severely bad i i'm actually talking i
don't know if we're gonna cut this or
keep this i'm actually talking to um
detectives right now about one of my
stalkers it's so bad well i am he used
to stalk me but now he's resorted to
sistine unfortunately you're very
detailed
sorry also screw you
yeah but it's like no we never had any
stalker or like no like crazy not real
like stalkers like showing up places
right like coming to every hotel or like
yeah whatever that is maybe like sending
dms to other people like trying to be
crazy and start some stuff
okay yeah that's pretty
loco yeah i don't love that no crazy
enough on that end but nothing
yeah so what are you looking forward to
for this upcoming season what are you
coming here in this upcoming year yeah
what's your new year's resolution what's
your what's your goals
wow we're so good at our job we're so
good at this
i don't know new year's resolution i
mean
it's the same every year it's trying to
read more and how does it happen well
you're
yesterday that i have like
i brought home from st louis like five
books i was like okay i'm gonna read
four of these by the time the season
starts
i've read i've read one up to the next
one 20 pages a day you gotta just do it
or ten pages a day at night in the
morning on the bus no anything sophia is
crazy i'll walk into her room at 7 am
and she's reading i'm like sophia i read
i got to watch netflix i got it a month
three a month yeah well now i've kind of
committed myself to it because the book
club i try to read three and then i
review the three and then i go on to the
next but i do have a book i feel like
you would really like if you'd like not
fiction books
relentless by tim grover read that one
it's a great one
that's a that's a great one he has a new
one a desi yeah it's a new one called
winning that i have currently sitting on
my table at home see i like that because
i like that student becomes the master
no but i'm schooling you on both it's a
great book because it's all about
mindset and having that no [ __ ] like
no excuses yeah my friends play the
first chapter of that book is called
don't think relentless oh my god that's
the science i didn't know that but he
pointed out like after we were he he
read it i don't know a year ago and he
opens it and he's like he sent me a
picture i was like how funny that
actually makes sense because that's kind
of
basically your entire
like who you are i mean the entire first
chapter is all about like don't
overthink just do the job get into it
don't
like i like that you read books that
sort of you can actually apply to your
try to a lot of mental yeah mental books
or people who have been through things
yeah yeah see i'm a more fiction fantasy
person and love so you want some romance
novels definitely
murder novels i got you she wants some
also veronica we got some of those too
you're the murderer novels and she's i
was gonna make it the wrong i was gonna
make a joke saying that like no because
i said you would apply to your books to
your life and i was like i can't oh you
oh
yeah i got you i i saw it so your goal
is just to do exactly as you've been
doing and read more books i mean it's
just getting better each and every day
like what can i do to get one percent
better every day okay whether it's i
don't know reading it i don't know
simple things
i like it as a man i highly stress if
you want to join us we're going to make
vision boards tomorrow so yeah if you
want a scrapbook
yes this was so much fun yeah thank you
so i feel like i learned so much about
you about baseball i hope the next time
we hang out maybe we can like play wii
baseball watch bench warmers or
something in that nature
watch everything involving face masks
i think it makes sense we're really
excited for your upcoming season
honestly i'm i'm supporting you i'll
make a poster and the fact that you came
on unwax today we didn't even think you
would come so we're so stoked to have
you here no you're one of our favorite
guests and i actually mean that so yeah
seriously this is fine and you can find
him at jack flaherty on instagram
anything else
i got nothing else perfect watch him
stand on the mound guys on the rubber on
the rubber with eight nine innings
there's not eight dollars
well thank you guys so much for tuning
in this week we will see you next
tuesday
[Music]
you